prendre rendez-vous pour jeter ses
déchets la nouvelle règle pour accéder
aux sept déchetteries de saint quentin
en yvelines depuis la réouverture le 4
mai dernier les habitants du territoire
doivent se rendre sur une plateforme
internet pour choisir le créneau horaire
et la déchetterie je me renseigner à la
mairie pour savoir comment ça fonctionne
et et après j'ai téléphoné à 50 ha et
j'ai pris des rendez vous et voilà
watcha fonctionne très bien exploité par
véolia les employés de ce site ont
adopté les gestes barrières pour
respecter au mieux les règles sanitaires
les consignes glace et le respect des
règles sanitaires de venir seul vous
arrivez à une table où vous posez votre
carte
l'agent scan la carte sans la toucher et
vous les reprenez il n'y absolument
voilà on a on a essayé de gérer sans
aucun contact en retrait de composteurs
de sacs de déchets verts ou encore
facturation du traitement des déchets
pour les professionnels d'autres
services de nouveau disponible fermé
depuis le 17 mars la réouverture était
attendue par les usagers
c'est une forte demande déjà des
administrés donc ils sont manifestés
pour qu'on les ré ouvre donc ça c'est la
première conséquence donc quelque part
c'est positif parce que ça veut dire que
c'est un outil aujourd'hui qui est
rentré dans les moeurs
le deuxième mandat on l'a bien vu que
sur le porte à porte les gens qui
pouvaient pas évacuer leurs déchets
verts lors choses comme ça on a eu des
doses augmentent tonneau de tonnage sur
le porte à porte sur les sept
établissements de l'agglomération plus
de 17 mille tonnes de produits sont
récoltés par an 80% de ces déchets sont
recyclés